riots erupted across France for a third
straight night following the deadly
police shooting of a 17-year-old during
a traffic stop and a Paris suburb
earlier this week French officials
report look at this more than 600
arrests Nationwide and say around 250
police officers have been so have been
injured Elaine Cobb has more from Paris
protesters launched fireworks at Riot
police in the suburbs of Paris torched
cars and set buildings on fire as
thousands took to the streets for a
third night in a row
police responded in large numbers with
40 000 deployed in an attempt to restore
order demonstrators are accusing the
police of racism and excessive force
after a 17 year old named Nile of
Algerian Moroccan descent was shot at
close range by a police officer during a
traffic stop police alleged Niall
refused to stop his car he died from his
wounds the officer who shot Nile has
apologized to the family he's been
placed under formal investigation for
voluntary homicide
his mother led a march on Thursday
demanding Justice for her son
anti-racist activist Tracy leggee says
these things happen when you're French
but with foreign Roots we're not
considered French they only look at the
color of our skin but for CBS mornings
Elaine Cobb Paris